salut tout le monde j'espère que vous
allez bien on est hyper content avec
l'équipe des documentaires de brut de
pouvoir vous proposer gratuitement sur
Youtube notre série sur les Black
Dragons si vous ne savez pas qui sont je
vous donne un tout petit peu de contexte
avant de lancer le premier épisode on
est en France au début des années 80
dans les quartiers populaires des
grandes villes il y a des descentes de
skinhead des milices racistes qui
s'aiment la terreur et il y a plusieurs
groupes qui vont s'opposer à eux dont
les blagues dragons c'est un gang créé
par un ancien Black Panther qui est né
Haïti il est assez fascinant et je pense
vous allez comprendre pourquoi dans ce
cul je vous en dis pas plus bon
visionnage
tous ces mecs c'est des combattants
à l'époque les Black Dragons beaucoup
ont des titres beaucoup ont des des
ceintures taekwondo boxe anglaise boxe
thaï pied point c'est des combattants
Black Dragon si on sait pas se battre
le problème c'est que ils ont besoin de
cobaye et ben nous c'était nous et puis
attendez à cette époque là on a enfin on
a tous 13 ans on est des gamins et tout
le temps systématiquement dès qu'ils
avaient besoin de tester leur dernier
coup leur dernier geste leur dernier
combo comme on dit il venait qu'est-ce
qui se passe venez poser il fermait la
porte dès qu'on savait qu'il ferme la
porte de la chambre ah on a les souffrir
ah oui mon petit cousin
lui je l'ai initié je l'ai formé et puis
là ils nous mettent des combos
coup de coude et puis lui se protéger se
défendaient mais on prenait le dessus on
prend une servi de sacs des frappes il
vient
rien de tout ça
mais de la vraie bagarre on est des on
est des sparines partner
[Musique]
à son frère que en fait on l'avait un
peu traumatisé quand même avec les amis
qui sortirait pas Adele de ça et ben si
[Musique]
nomène
fête de l'actualité des banlieues
cette bande de zoulou des blagues
dragons ils vivent dans les cités de
banlieue ils deviennent de plus en plus
violents
[Musique]
la victime a été tuée d'une balle dans
la nuque au cours d'un affrontement
entre deux bandes rivales
ça c'est un coup de couteau
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et il vous l'avez pas eu pour l'instant
non
je dois avoir pas mal de casseroles
parce que c'est pour ça qu'il se cache
moi je sais que par exemple pour
rencontrer Yves le vent le chef des
dragons noirs j'ai passé deux mois
toutes les semaines il me donnait
rendez-vous à un café à côté d'une cité
il ne venait jamais
au bout de deux mois il a apparu attends
c'est quoi ton truc là de me faire venir
de toutes les semaines il me dit j'étais
avec des jumelles je vérifiais qu'il y
avait pas la police qui était avec toi
j'ai eu beaucoup de mal à photographier
les blagues dragons j'ai eu à vrai dire
que le chef je le vent si vous avez une
interview de lui c'est que vous avez
gagné déjà vous voyez ce que quelqu'un
qui était très discret pour la cause et
que pour la cause
[Musique]
la photo emblématique qui est là donc on
a Yves Yves le vent le gourou
[Musique]
je voulais voir ce qu'il a une bombe
atomique
c'était quand même type très très fort
je veux dire il faisait des bons de 2m50
de haut en faisant des dépliés des
châteaux de tout ce que vous voulez
c'était très impressionnant l'équipe ça
fait vraiment se battre moi j'ai vu des
combats comme ça c'était il y avait des
bons des sources rien que dans un film
de karaté avec
shiny là je sais plus comment il
s'appelle non non vraiment c'est
impressionnant
alors voilà une photo que j'ai mis près
de deux mois avant de pouvoir la
réaliser
Yves le vent me donne rendez-vous à côté
cette barre d'immeuble dans un terrain
vague et là il commence une
démonstration de force et de kung-fu
pour montrer qu'il est le Black Dragon
le plus efficace le plus fort de tous
les blacksdragon
deux ans son apprenti il va lui
apprendre autre chose
quand on adversaire tu ne peux pas le
éliminer par quelques coups de pieds tu
lui tranches la gorge
une machine à tuer et dit le vent
faire vivre du bien
[Musique]
dans l'esprit de Yves on est très
un peu comme des chevaliers
[Musique]
certains ont pensé que c'était une sorte
de naïveté mais pour nous c'était ça
être un homme
[Musique]
ceux qui nous différencer des autres
groupes c'est justement le code
d'honneur qu'on avait et c'est quoi ce
codeur
ne pas boire ni fumer et être prêt au
combat
[Musique]
vive le vent c'est un Haïtien il arrive
d'Haïti dans les années 80 au début des
années 80 donc quand il arrive on se
rend compte qu'il est un peu différent
des autres ils pensent différemment de
nous et tout ça quoi lui avait déjà vu
le monde par rapport à nous il avait
déjà vu beaucoup de choses dans le monde
et avec déjà beaucoup de choses se
passaient en Haïti
Yves était déjà dans un autre niveau il
était déjà adulte dans sa tête
c'est son beau-père en fait qui est
parti à Miami et qui a créé un groupe
qui s'appelle les blagues dragons et
Yves a pris ce nom et leur amener ici
Black Dragon c'est un concept qui vient
des États-Unis pour les gens qui
connaissent alors moi je connais
l'histoire parce que j'étais j'ai grandi
dans depuis tout petit tout petit mais
c'est vrai que il voulait voir un très
grand respect parce qu'il a quand même
réuni pas mal de gens autour de cette
cause quand même quand on rencontre Yves
les plaques dragons on sait pas ce que
c'est avec un 16 ans ou même vers 17 ans
c'est parce que c'est elle nous explique
qu'en fait il chasse les skins et
l'injustice parce que il va à la base le
créateur c'est un Black Panthers
quand on a pris l'histoire des Black
Panthers dans ces reconnu on s'est dit
mais oui mais c'est exactement ça des
gens qui combattent pour leur liberté ou
leur droit de vivre tout simplement
c'est noble les premières bandes issues
de l'immigration comme les Black Panther
c'est de leur but c'était de se défendre
face à tous ces groupes racistes au
début le mouvement c'est on descend un
autre communauté
[Musique]
la conscience politique qu'on avait
laissé à ce moment-là
on a appris de déplacer on a pris de
l'histoire de Martin Luther King
l'histoire de Malcolm X on a pris
beaucoup de choses entre nous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis fier d'être né gros en gros un
vrai gros un de gros du Fier de
tous mes gars et tous les dragons je
suis fier des bons comme des mauvais
il y a le sentiment très fort
d'appartenir à la communauté noire ça
c'est quand même très important
Yves dit le vent avait une idée
syncrétique de du rôle des blagues
dragons qui étaient la paix la paix la
bienveillance parce que quand même des
c'était des gros bastonner mais la paix
a bienveillance et faire régner la paix
sur terre donc ça c'est une philosophie
qui l'avait retirée d'Haïti et donc il
voulait implanter ça dans les gangs les
voyants que vous allez voir maintenant
sont beaucoup plus actuelles on ne sait
pas s'il deviendront d'honnête père de
famille pour l'instant ils vivent dans
la haine dans la violence la bière le
racisme et leur idole c'est l'heure
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je me suis mis là les gants parce que
j'étais outré de voir toutes ces choses
là tous ces choses et
ces personnes qui prenaient des coups de
pied au cul parce qu'il était black
dans les années 80
il passe leur journée à signer des
graffitis et boire de la bière en
attendant les ratonnades nocturnes moi
je peux vous garantir que à cette époque
là vous marchiez pas dans les métros
vous marchez pas la défense vous marchez
pas dans la rue c'est pas possible porte
monnaie on était apeuré et en plus ils
étaient comme des ministres à cette
époque-là ils prenait des voitures 3 4
voitures il se baladaient dans les
quartiers ils attendaient de tomber sur
des gens des noirs des arabes pour leur
pour les agresser c'est un peu quoi donc
il y avait une vraie chasse à l'homme de
leur côté et des gens ont souffert oui
des gens ont souffert et c'est pour ça
qu'on a été qu'on a existé vous avez bon
les porter plainte au commissariat c'est
ça restait avec la saison suite quoi
voilà donc à partir d'un moment il
fallait bien que quelqu'un se
retroussait les manches on est noir de
peau certains ne me supportent pas parce
que nous sommes noirs
on va pas on va pas leur dire oui de
d'accord on ferme notre bouche et puis
on se tourne non non c'est pas comme ça
on a grandi ici aussi on a grandi à
l'école de la République on veut la
liberté et l'égalité comme tout le monde
je le dis les blancs dragons c'est les
plus grands chasseurs de skin de Paris
dans les descentes oui on était là on a
essayé des plumes à l'époque on descend
dans le quartier latin
on a une cinquantaine soixantaine il y
avait le stress vraiment il y a le
stress il y a tout ça il y a plein de
choses
ils me disent des moments je suis dans
le mais qu'est-ce que je fais là
qu'est-ce que je fais la pensée mes
parents tu me poses plein de questions
et après quand on arrive on ne
s'attendait pas à voir autant de ce
qu'il
en face ils ont des points américains
des battes de baseball de l'acide
de l'acide et oui dès ma première
descente j'ai vu de l'acide
j'ai un ami qui a reçu donc un liquide
sur son blouson son blouson fondé son
bombers fondé il y a la bagarre qui se
fait des flics arrivent on se sauve tous
que ce soit les skins nous on se sauve
on se disperse mais on s'est battu mais
qu'est-ce que j'ai aimé ça qu'est-ce que
j'ai aimé ça c'était vraiment c'était
Yves je décide de faire des sections
pour pouvoir faire des chasses par
petits groupes donc vous avez des cobras
les kamikazes vous avez les tigres vous
avez les frégats et du coup il y a par
section il y a un chef
[Musique]
j'ai choisi de créer une comme les
Forces Spéciales quoi des frégates avec
un petit grain dans la tête bien sûr 90%
des blagues dragon s'entraîner taekwondo
box etc maintenant quand ils allaient
affronter des personnes qui ressortaient
des soins des couteaux ou soit des armes
donc forcément vous avez passé des armes
à la sur eux là il nous faisait appel à
voilà donc nous on intervenait et on
nettoyait la situation donc vous vous
étiez tous ça mais du coup les frégates
on va dire
pour me rappeler des dernières descentes
il fallait deux RER
quand vous attendez deux RER
c'est que des plus de 1000 personnes
franchement si vous êtes sensé Dieu
c'est une preuve de votre peau il y
avait une personne qui a un chef d'un
parce qu'il y a des skinness aussi
c'était comme ça et des clans aussi et
je te jure je n'ai repéré on en a repéré
un là qui voulait pas lâcher sans Nazar
vous voulez pas lâcher sans laser
et tous les jours littéraires et tous
les jours un soir je me suis dit bon
écoute les frérot moi moi j'ai rentré à
la défense moi je rentre pas et le mec
je l'ai pissé et puis c'était juste
voilà j'espère que ce premier épisode
vous a plu c'est Nicolas Dumont et
Mathias silian qui ont réalisé cette
série dans notre équipe documentaire si
vous voulez voir tous les épisodes des
blagues dragon sachez qu'ils sont d'ores
et déjà disponibles en intégralité dans
la brute sinon je vous donne rendez-vous
ici sur la chaîne Youtube de brut dans
deux semaines merci encore pour votre
soutien à très vite